situe à 9 ans et demi tu ne pourras pas
comprendre cette vidéo à moins que tu es
consommer un max de drogue
[Musique]
le jour de ses 25 ans tout le monde te
dis la même phrase alors un quart de
siècle quand les gens et d un quart de
siècle du direct tu pense à un truc
le petit graphique de la vie sauf que
dans le quatrième quart battez est mort
en fait dans le troisième quart quant à
la retraite ou alors tu regardes des
chiffres et des lettres
donc finalement à 25 ans et reste plus
qu'à moitié de ta vie active mais cabade
oublié je vais partir un petit peu en
vacances pour une semaine je prends le
train façon à la sncf où la carte 12-25
book
ah bah non ah bah non du coup je n'ai
plus à parfait tu as 25 ans tu as plus
en plus de potes qui veulent faire des
soirées entre couples soirée entre deux
couples y a pas plus raciste que le
concept des soirées entre couples ouais
ce soir en soi une petite soirée couple
avec frais des carreaux à yann soirée ce
soir je peux venir banon taux dépend le
couple toi ta vie c'est de la merde
donc tu vas rentrer chez toi ce soir
tout seul tu vas manger des pâtes dures
agressé quatre story le mec il est
célibataire il veut venir à notre soirée
impro qu'ils font c'est génial c'est pas
génial
à 25 ans tu manges plus trop sucrés tu
préfères le salé et égouts change
je prends mon café sans sucre à saveur
je vais prendre un café noir sublet
cours serait puissant sans sucre
s'entassent et sans café s'il vous plaît
merci c'est nickel ou non j'adore la
bretagne
j'ai déjà pêché quelques truites là et
même des fois au resto quand serveur me
propose la carte des desserts
je réponds je vais prendre le fromage
souplet sans sucre maintenant j'avais
bien le chocolat noir
[Musique]
je fais mon que sakho la noire au avant
quand je faisais les soirées entre potes
la table basse du salon à ressembler à
ça maintenant 8 ans ressemble à ça
reparte en bretagne la bretagne c'est
magnifique
les crêpes les crêpes la table basse des
gens nature à 25 ans ton corps commence
à grossir
tu prends conscience qu'il faudrait
peut-être que tu commences à faire du
sport en fête alors j'ai acheté un tapis
de gym je les déplier puis de les ranger
dans mon placard puis en fait j'ai
jamais fait de sport 25 ans tu commence
à voir des potes qui ont déjà des
enfants
et quand ils montrent leurs enfants en
photo tu es obligé d'avoir cette
réaction
je regarde ça c'est mon gamin il a deux
ans au le tube bout'chou comment il est
trop mignon
il est à croquer c'est carrément
hypocrite tu vas jamais avoir une
réaction sincère et ça c'est mon gamin
il a deux ans ah non non j'aime pas je
passe déjà par son style jeu n'ont
parfois même je commence à dire des
phrases de vieux
[Musique]
sm on n'est pas que ça
j'écoutais pas je connais moi j'écoutais
pas ça moi j'écoutais cornes
quand je vois certains de mes potes sur
facebook donc déjà une femme qui sont
mariés qui ont un enfant je me dis qu'on
n'a pas tous dans le cinq ans de la même
façon en fait si tu veux depuis qu'on
est là môme est clos et on s'est
installé
j'ai fait un petit prêt à la banque que
je me suis acheté une clio sport voit se
passe très très bien et toi tu dirais
quoi alors depuis le temps ben moi
j'essaye de passer mon permis
sinon je cherche un stage d'ailleurs
enfin c'est à dire j'ai reçu un mail
d'un mec qui voudrait faire un stage
avec moi je te réponds peu le délire
parce que je suis petite vidéo tout seul
je pense que je pourrais faire avec un
stagiaire salut norman jeu tournez vos
stagiaires alors parfois on commence ben
je sais pas si tu veux tu veux on peut
aller faire les courses
c'est de la merde me casse faut que
j'arrête de m'habiller comme un gamin
manche à cergy lui il s'en fout il
s'habille comme i 2
à
abonne toi ma chaîne youtube en cliquant
ici
et tente sa chance pour peut-être gagner
un pin's
[Musique]